hi I'm Erik Bosse and the benches
infinity door was the culmination of
several threads in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it was pretty impressive to
see all these pieces come together in a
way that made sense as long as you don't
use the bathroom in the middle and go an
hour without seeing Iron Man Wow but
let's break down how infinity war fix
the overall MCU timeline and what events
went down off screen this set the stage
for at Thanos's arrival like we've been
wondering why only now did Danis attack
and infinity war actually justified have
been an interesting way also this video
is sponsored by Dollar Shave Club stick
around at the end of the video for
details about an exclusive offer that's
just for you guys and customary spoiler
warning if you haven't seen infinity war
yet ok first Infinity Ward restored the
traditional MCU timeline in which movies
generally take place in the year they
are released for example infinity war
takes place in 2018 Civil War took place
in 2016 and the first Avengers took
place in 2012 now we know this because
an infinity war vision and Scarlet Witch
mentioned that they had been in hiding
for two years it's two years since the
conflict in Civil War and then Brody
repeats this later when they all
reunited in Avengers HQ and when Tony
Stark argues with Doctor Strange on the
cue ship he snaps Thanos has been inside
my head for six years since he sent an
army to New York and now he's back that
sets the events of Avengers in 2012
now the reason some people got confused
about all this is spider-man homecoming
that movie's prologue scene took place
in the direct aftermath of the Battle of
New York and the Avengers in 2012 but
then in a dumb old title slide said
eight years later than cutting to Tony
dropping off Peter following the Civil
War event which wasn't eight years later
it was four years later Marvel has now
actually clarified that the homecoming
thing was indeed a mistake so we should
ignore it it didn't happen eight years
leaders like I don't feel so good
but infinity war actually rewrites the
whole MCU timeline and clarifies a lot
of questions we had Marvel Studios has
done an amazing job laying out a
specific series of events that set up
the rise of Thanos so what was the mad
Titan doing all this time out there in
space why didn't he attack before
sending Loki to retrieve the space
stones tesseract and Avengers or why not
attack while the Avengers had their
hands tied with ultron or in their own
internal conflict in civil war well
infinity war combined with a few of the
recent MCU movies gives us all the
evidence to assemble the whole
background timeline of this when Thor
travels to Nineveh Lear to get a new
hammer
he runs into a tree who reveals that
Thanos and his forces had invaded them
and forced him to forge a new way to
contain all six Infinity stones at once
the Infinity Gauntlet this was a major
turning point in Thanos's mission for
years he had been searching for the six
magic bullets and now with the gauntlet
he had the gun to fire them and this
game-changer was a direct consequence of
Odin's departure the end of Thor the
dark world revealed that Loki was still
alive posing as Odin we learned in Thor
Ragnarok that look he had stowed Odin in
a retirement home in New York and Odin
ended up wandering to a cliffside in
Norway where he died a few scenes
earlier Thor accused Loki who was still
disguised as Odin at the time of letting
the defenses of the nine realms one of
which is natively fall apart but then I
decided to go out there and investigate
and what do I find but the nine realms
completely in chaos enemies of Asgard
assembling plotting our demise all while
you open the protector of those nine
realms is sitting here in your bathrobe
eating grapes Odin's absence in later
death caused all kinds of problems
it allowed hellah to return and Thorin
Loki in hopes of stopping her release
searcher who destroyed Asgard leaving
the space stone tesseract unprotected
and yes Odin's absence allowed Fanus to
finally obtain a way to harness all the
Infinity stones and use them through a
space blacksmith Peter Dinklage now
completely open to attack
this led to the moment that we saw in
the post-credits scene after age of
Ultron where Thanos puts on the Infinity
Gauntlet which doesn't yet have the
Infinity stones I know that's a little
confusing since the age of Ultron was
set in 2015 whereas Ragnarok was set in
2017 so did Thanos sit around with that
gauntlet for like two or three years
before heading to Xander maybe really
these Marvel post-credits scenes tend to
be separate from the events of the
movies that precede them but here's how
I think it all went down after World War
two howards stark recovered the
tesseract and a 2010 shield launched
project Pegasus to research its power
2012 a Aniston's Loki with an army and a
mine stone in the scepter to retrieve
the space stone Loki fails space stone
relocated to Asgard
2013 Loki fakes his death in unseats
Odin cosmic chaos begins reality stone
moved to the collector and nowhere 2014
Thanos since Ronan to retrieve the Power
Stone Ronan fails thanks to the
guardians of the galaxy Power Stone kept
in a vault Ahn's and are then
sometime between 2015 and 2018 Thanos
exploits Asgard's collapse as the cosmic
protector to attacks middle ear finally
getting an Infinity Gauntlet to contain
all the stones 2016 the time stone
appears on earth under the control the
sorcerer supreme Doctor Strange 2017
Odin dies Asgard destroyed and locate
Lutz's space stone from Odin's vault key
Thor and Hulk are left wandering in
space which brings us to 2018 Wakanda
has made its presence known to the world
and unfortunately to any other enemies
who might want to attack it during this
time at some point off-screen Thanos a
taxes and are stealing the Power Stone
Thor reports this to us and regarding to
the galaxy and Infinity Ward shortly
after that Fanus uses a Power Stone to
attack the Asgardian survivors and take
the space stone there after retrieving
the rest of the stones one by one the
reality stone from nowhere the soul
stone from Boromir the time stone from
Doctor Strange on Titan in the mine
stone from vision in Wakanda on earth
now the next movie on the MCU calendar
is ant-man and the wasp which will come
out in July now we don't know for sure
yet but it seems like that movie will
take place before the events of Avengers
infinity war based on the footage we've
seen Scott Lang and the rest don't
appeared that concern with the crisis of
half the world's population disappearing
now it's possible of that crisis is
affecting the world somewhere in the
background and we're just not seeing it
in this footage yet but I think it's
more likely that ant-man the wasp will
take place before Thanos his arrival and
it'll and maybe by tying back to the
ending of infinity war with some of
those characters suddenly leading away
and freaking each other out same goes
for the upcoming Captain Marvel which
will come out in March 2019 but that
will be set earlier in the 1990s and I
predicted my end by tying in to the
events infinity war in 2018 also for
those of you watching agents of shield
we've been learning in these final
episodes of season 5 that these events
are actually tied to the Infinity war
timeline the most recent episode
referenced Thanos directly Thanos and
his forces have begun an assault on your
world even as we speak well then I've
got to get down there with the Avengers
and take on this danos now the upcoming
season finale may be ages the shield's
final episode ever meaning this series
could end at the same time Thanos snaps
his fingers
I assume the snap will also impact the
world of the Marvel Netflix heroes who
have only really lightly referenced the
Battle New York and past seasons
I actually think the upcoming season of
Luke Cage will also take place before
the Infinity Ward events whoo that's a
lot of events and dates so I'll turn it
over to you guys looking at this whole
series of events as a whole who do you
think is more
Blayne birth bonuses rise to power Loki
or Thor locates Medellin certainly cause
chaos that baños was able to exploit but
remember Thor also left the reality
stone and a pretty lousy hiding spot
nowhere dude go for the head comment
down below with your thoughts this video
was sponsored by Dollar Shave Club I'm
finally gonna be shaving this mug next
week guys so you'll get to see the baby
pace in the flesh unfortunately Thanos
cannot snap this away so I'll need to do
it myself
and yea there's just too many options at
the pharmacy and it's just easy to get
stuck with the razor and accessories you
don't really want her need so if you're
like me and you're sick of a nonsense at
the store now is the time to try out
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their shower and shaves starter set
to new members for only 5 bucks this
starter set features their executive
razor and 3 trial size versions of their
most popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean and your first boxer
will receive their shea butter and body
wash and one of my Charlie's pet wipes
guys any more than just razors your
girlfriend who goes to another school
thank you and yeah you'll also receive
their executive razor which includes
their premium weighty handle and a full
cassette of cartridges after the first
box replacement cartridges are sent for
only a few bucks a month this offer is
exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com slash new rock stars
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash new
rock stars or click on the link in the
description below guys supporting Dollar
Shave Club enables them to support this
channel so you're really doing
yourselves and us a favor by checking
this out and you can tweet me directly
at us or follow new rockstars on Twitter
for updates on our videos like and share
this video subscribe to New York sirs
for all of our deep dives and analyses
and explainers of ventures infinity war
thanks for watching bye
[Music]